on Tuesday Fox News's website had an
article about the luxury and cost of the
president's vacation the never-ending
vacations but I'm not talking about the
current president Donald Trump they were
talking about the last guy Barack Obama
here is a headline from fox news
politics website Obama is under fire
from the left for never ending sizzling
ultra luxury vacations two days before
this article was published Donald Trump
spent the entire weekend at trump
National Golf Club in Virginia something
he's done regularly playing more golf
than any president in history after
promising he wouldn't really be leaving
the White House because there's so much
work to be done was Donald Trump at the
golf club making important deals no the
White House reported that he was indeed
there playing golf and Fox News is using
more or less the same strategy as the
Trump White House which is when Trump
messes up or creates some sort of
scandal which is basically every day Fox
News scrambles to avert your attention
to something that either Obama dater is
doing or something that Hillary Clinton
allegedly did or is doing or the
Democrats did wrong often it's something
bogus with no real substance and this
time Fox News is actually having the
audacity to blame Obama right now for
something that Donald Trump is doing
right now this weekend Donald Trump took
his 30th golf trip as president at which
time he had been in office for 155 days
meaning that since he took office
Trump has on average gone golfing once
every five days so what is Fox News do
in response they start criticizing
Barack Obama going on vacation after
leaving office and for example an
article about Barack Obama going to
Necker Island was floating around in the
British Virgin Islands that's where
Necker Island is who cares if President
Obama is going on vacation after his
presidency Fox News took an out of
context quote from a Democratic
strategist and created this narrative
that the left is just furious with Obama
because he's vacationing now that he no
longer has a job sort of a perfect
microcosm of Fox News right Fox News
exists to serve the Republican Party
to pander to their conservative low
information audience creating these
salacious and misleading headlines
Obama's vacations are sizzling pad oh
boy start the presses they're also still
on this elitist critique oh yeah
President Obama saying
sizzling ultra luxury vacations Obama's
net worth is some twelve million dollars
largely from book sales maybe that will
increase because of all the Wall Street
speeches that he's now doing yeah
but their current president has a net
worth of supposedly three and a half
billion dollars at the lowest guys not
even a self-made man he made it from
real estate and television so how could
you still be on that Pat anybody can
become as rich as Trump as long as you
just get your dad to give you a small
loan of a million dollars when the
genetic lottery that's all you need yeah
the real headline for this article
should be Obama enjoying his life after
being harassed by extremists and racists
for eight years many of whom questioned
whether he was an American citizen
that's what you call an accurate
headline and we've talked many times on
the show about the the hypocrisy here as
well which is that during Barack Obama's
presidency Donald Trump sent out dozens
of tweets about how Obama was playing
too much golf right remember the endless
tweets about Obama playing too much golf
and it's Trump who's playing the golf at
this point in his presidency President
Obama had gone golfing eight times and
like I told you just minutes ago Trump
played his 30th round of golf this
weekend since taking office and the
other day Pat asked whether I watch Fox
News with any regularity we off the air
we were talking about it and I said I
really don't anymore I've kind of
forgotten what it's like and I actually
tuned in the other day it's total
hysteria
I mean Hannity is unhinged completely
Tucker Carlson's demeanor makes him seem
slightly more sane but if you listen to
the words he's saying you realize he's
unhinged they've got this show the five
which is arguably the most ludicrous
show on cable news today and Fox and
Friends went off the deep end years ago
it is it is exponentially harder to
watch Fox News now than it was five
years ago maybe it's because I've gotten
desensitized or I guess I'm
resynthesized to it from not watching I
don't know maybe now because Trump's
president they have to excuse him on so
many things and one more thing on this I
think it's
early sign to critique the former
president because they may leave the
world in the economy in a different
position than it was in before maybe
that's worse off but with Obama they
can't really do that well these
vacations are sizzling pad I mean that's
a serious hard-hitting story and many
people on our discussion forum talking
about this you can join us there at
david pakman.com slash reddit I'm on
there Pat checks it out as well join us
there we'll be back after this today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in too I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS